hello i'll be with you in just a moment
apparently there's a youtube easter egg
but i need to wait
so give me a minute
hold on
hello hi
welcome to the stream i'll probably have
to reiterate this a few times i just saw
a post saying that there was some kind
of an easter egg on youtube
and i wanted to try it
live because why not
um so you may have seen this post where
if you delete a certain thing in the
youtube url
it takes you somewhere that might be
nightmare fuel
and i thought why not
let's see if it actually happens and
then i thought why not
let's see if it actually happens on
stream
uh so i'm going to find out
i'm just giving it a few minutes for
more people to be here
might get my channel banned
who knows it's not going to be the same
this isn't anything that i have come up
with this is nothing that i've done
in the interim i have no plans on this i
have not seen this
uh it might all be bunk
but i'm gonna try it anyway i might be
trolled
um
yeah so apparently there's an easter egg
of some kind where if you delete a
certain character in the url it goes
somewhere specific
so i'm going to find out where it goes
live on stream um so in just a few
moments i'll try it out and then
probably get my channel banned or
something
why it's nice nothing no literally this
is nothing that i've done
um this is a post that i saw
on reddit
and they said don't do this so what am i
doing i'm doing it but i'm doing it live
on stream okay
mark no no
it's too late
this can't backfire at all hey
i appreciate the optimism
that better not get banned eh what's the
worst that could happen but apparently
it's some kind of a nightmare fuel so i
don't know what this is so to explain it
again for those of you just joining here
there's apparently an
easter egg
with youtube where if you delete a
certain thing in the youtube url when
you're on any video
it goes somewhere
i don't know where it goes
i don't know if it's viruses i don't
know if it's porn i don't know what it
is
but it goes somewhere
so i'm going to
see where it goes
if i get banned
getting banned speed run irl uh world
record yeah this is what this is going
to be um so i'm just giving it a couple
more minutes
if you get a virus i'm gonna laugh well
we're all gonna be laughing
all right just a little bit longer
don't know if this is a good idea hey
you usually whenever i have one of these
bad ideas it turns out to be a decent
idea at least that's how it worked out
for uh pokemon smasher pass so i thought
why not on this
um
yeah cross your fingers everybody
this is
gonna be uh probably a whole lot of
nothing
and i
no i'm not joking about this this this
is a in the last stream of course i was
just doing a non-stop bit where i was
like pretending like something was going
to happen this may be absolutely nothing
what it is is you go to any youtube
video and then you delete a certain
character in the url so every time you
pull up a youtube video there's a url
and a code
for the video that you're watching it's
it's a random string of numbers and
letters that lets you lets youtube know
what video that is and that's
permanently tied to that video but
apparently if you edit one thing out of
that it goes somewhere else
tell us the character don't be shy no
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do this for
you guys so that you guys don't have to
uh experience whatever horrors
are there i need to run now i mean maybe
i'll run after i find out what it is i'm
just going to give it another minute or
two before people uh
get in here
yeah so like i said
my current my audio's bit rate is zero i
don't think it's zero
oh oops it's a little low
am i coming off a little row body
and it don't matter
does it matter
it's probably a little roboty
does it sound like buddy
and it don't matter
does it matter
it's probably a little roboty
what does it sound like nah it's fine
it's fine 64 uh kilobits a second is
plenty for audio so what this is it's
either an easter egg or it's a bug it's
one or the other i don't think that this
is probably an intentional thing unless
it is because honestly i don't know what
it is but it is a thing that people say
that when you go there they wish they
didn't see it so i'm to do this live to
prove that it is or is not a thing that
you would like to see or not
it might be terrible it might be cool
i don't know we'll find out all right
that should be enough people it's been
about five minutes uh so
baba booey
i've got
youtube this is youtube.com well let me
show you this isn't fake it's
youtube.com
right on youtube.com
regular old youtube plenty of videos
here i'm not logged in this is incognito
like uh so no
uh changing of anything buy me
probably the best
scrambled eggs netflix just got much
worse for whatever reason news
uh
sports
deep focus some ridiculous like
apartment it is i didn't think it was
youtube
it just is
plain old youtube
baba booey
um
you know those situations where someone
was right
right huge it's just i'm going look i'm
i'm just on a critical rabbit hole this
is a kind of an accident i didn't mean
to do this this was just on the home
page
and then
i have no idea bill nye goes sneaker
shopping
i don't know
that's probably fine but that's not the
point so the bug or whatever it is is
apparently to do with the url here
and if i remember right it is deleting
the h
in watch
so if i do that
it's going to go somewhere
apparently
this is
the easter egg so i'm gonna
count down ten
from ten
ten
nine
eight
seven
six if it's a rick roll i'm gonna be
very mad
four
three
two
one
oh interesting that loud sorry
sorry that's probably very loud
interesting
fascinating
interesting
hold on a second by the way uh this is a
video that i was in in corridor there's
a reason not a promo just
this game up here
look there i am anyway i've been
interning with them so this is a
completely different video right
so the question is
you delete h in watch and it's a
different video url right it's a
different series of numbers and letters
right
interesting
fascinating
what is all
ooh
interesting
should i go to this i don't know if i
should go to this channel i don't know
if i should
am i cursed am i now cursed am i cursed
forever i think i might be cursed
forever
okay
well
that's interesting what happens if i do
it when i'm here
right okay
same place comes right back here
this is it uh so if you want to do this
for yourself
it's just some troll channel but the
question is i'm sure it's just some
troll channel the question is why does
this happen
so if you're on desktop or mobile and
you you're watching this mobile and not
the app you can probably change the url
probably on this very stream that you're
currently on
you can go here
and you can delete the h
and watch
and for some reason
it goes to this
video and now i'm sure there's nothing
incredible about this video
interesting
hello everybody my name is
but you go to any other video you delete
h
and it goes there now the question is if
i delete any other letter does it go
anywhere else
it goes the same place or is that just
because it was already there and it kind
of like bugged out hold on let me go
here i'm going to delete the c
it still goes here
delete the t
ah that doesn't do anything
weird what about the a
you know dasher and dancer and prancer
and vixen
cometh
what
what why is there no title
i'm
interesting
fascinating what about the w
okay that's not found so apparently that
c and h go to that same video and then a
goes
here for some reason
i have no idea
i don't know what's going on
that
is weird
that's
very strange
i don't know what to think about that
that's interesting
and that's
i mean i think that's the extent of it i
i don't know i'm kind of tempted to look
at that other video
on their channel
oh interesting okay so to get to this
other video
so look at this here
i'm on this channel which is the one
that these link to
and if i click on this one which i'm
seeing a leg here and i'm
not sure what's going on but if you
click on it it says sign in to confirm
your age for some reason this one has
been age restricted
so hang on i gotta
i gotta find out what this is
hold on a second
hold on everybody
hold on
yeah you know i don't know i don't know
about that one yeah i don't know about
that one
i don't know about that one i don't i
don't think
no i don't think i'm gonna show you that
one
pretty sure that one doesn't need to be
for sure that one doesn't need i'm
pretty sure that one doesn't need to be
i'm pretty sure that one doesn't need to
be seen
so
all right um okay so i think that's all
the to the easter egg but i am still
very very curious as to why that happens
um
it is something that i was not expecting
to actually be real but apparently it is
real so
there you have it congratulations you
can try it for yourself remember if you
delete the h or apparently the c as well
in the url it goes to that video and
then if you delete the
a
it goes to that minecraft video
i don't know
i have no idea
i don't know what it is i don't know
what it's about but uh it actually works
so i'm
i'm kind of interesting
but anyway um i forgot something uh very
important uh when i did my birthday
stream i forgot that i had a birthday
wish
and i didn't actually exercise the
birthday wish so i have something here
if you guys want to wish me the very
best birthday
uh what you can do
is you can
enjoy the brand new
go my favorite sports team youtube
channel
we've just launched it and yes uh it is
with tyler if you remember tyler we have
a podcast called go my favorite sports
team which i have not talked about too
much but go enjoy the uh youtube channel
it's just starting out we're gonna post
highlights here and then also we're
going to do sports related challenges
on this channel so subscribe because
tomorrow uh tyler is going to be
teaching me
various sport related things with
various sport related punishments um i'm
not sure that
i'm going to lose at all i'm pretty sure
i'm going to win all of them i don't
know a lot about sports
which is kind of the whole point of the
podcast so if you don't know a lot about
sports that's okay i don't either but
that's the excuse for me to talk to
tyler who knows a lot about sports uh so
so go subscribe it's youtube.com
gmfst uh don't remove any of the letters
or else you'll go somewhere very
different
so say happy birthday to me and then say
thank you to tyler for putting up with
my uh idiocy in terms of knowing
sportness and uh also thank the uh
animators for making such awesome
thumbnails for these uh highlights here
lots of cool stuff coming here lots of
sports really things uh tyler needs to
be my butler for a day we're gonna make
that video and then tyler uh probably is
going to be my chauffeur for a day so
you know it is what it is so thank you
for all the birthday wishes uh weird
youtube easter egg actually is the thing
um
gmfst
are there people subscribing
nice
nice
please do do go subscribe and do listen
to the podcast if you haven't had a
chance it's very good i'm very proud of
it and tyler misses you you know tyler
right you remember tyler stone face
tyler one word tyler he has many words
more in his belt under his belt around
his belt on this podcast go check it out
it's free like most of these things
very free
thank you
um and then delete other things
what if you delete the a and the c at
the same time
i don't know
i don't know
i doubt it goes anywhere but maybe who
knows hold on
one last little easter egg to find out
here
okay
[Music]
i'll do it
live
so the c and the h
nope
what
what about the c and the a oh everyone
go away
ah oh
i get it
ah
16 years ago wow this is a channel
youtube.com
wth what happens when you take out the c
and the a from watch you go
to
that
youtube channel through the url
ah
i get it
i get it
i get it
i get it
i get it
all right anyway
um i'm putting the url for gm fst in the
description if you guys couldn't find it
but it's uh go my favorite sports team
go check it out youtube.comgmfst
if you're already typing things into the
url type that one and check it out
there's some fun content some laughs to
be had and also i put it in the
description because i'm a good youtuber
actually knows what i'm doing so i get
it
they're exploiting the url because you
can customize the urls to make it
redirect to a channel but what i don't
know is how they're redirecting to a
video specifically because i know they
can take you to a channel but i didn't
know that could take you to a video
directly that
is the interesting part youtube easter
eggs are real all you have to do is go
find them
and also go find uh gmfst you'll like it
thank you all right i'ma leave now
farewell enjoy all the other spooky
easter eggs let me leave you with um
what do i have here
i went searching for the truth and
i went like a fool i found it
but
some truths
are best left on discovered i turned
around and there was
bigger than i could have imagined the
hikers claimed that when they turned
around it seemed as though their friend
had simply
vanished when i turned around
my whole farm was going i don't believe
in ghosts
[Music]
this is morbid mysteries of the missing
millennium
viewer discretion is advised
i see you guys i'm